[Music]
I was just checking the program actually
for today's talk I want to learn more
about data science in general
I wanted just to see what's around in
the newest uh area we're volunteering so
we're doing a range of things so we
could be Runners it could be
registration good morning by data
Amsterdam
it's about uh can we create an AI Utopia
where there's no possibility for our
killer robot AI machines so we're here
really just to connect with the
community but we had a lot of great
discussions with people here in
attendance at Pi data here in Amsterdam
oh I'm building really cool stuff that's
at the core of this business it's for
something that's actually helping the
world we make open source software for
[Music]
eign
foreign
[Music]
I found here many friends because I
think that network is the greatest
Capital right